[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to rotten
tomatoes
is wrong special shout out to all of our
returning champions and
new listeners hello i'm mark ellis i'm a
stand-up comic rotten tomatoes
correspondent
and son of odin
i'm jacqueline coley i'm an editor at
rotten tomatoes where i cover
independent film
and awards and i'm still laughing about
the fact that
mark ellis thinks he's a god did i sound
as guardian at all
uh and a little as guardian-ish
okay well look a lot of people debate
whether thor got his do or not whether
he got the shaft what he was doing in a
hot tub in this movie which is why we're
talking about
avengers age of ultron and it's also
jaclyn because one division was just
released on disney plus
and that stars wanda the black
scarlet witch excuse me not black widow
scarlet witch and vision and this is the
first time those two lovebirds met
was in avengers age of ultron or as i
call it avengers part
2. uh reminder that you all can get in
touch with us let us know what movies
you want us to be covering on upcoming
episodes all that sort of stuff whether
you think our opinion was right or wrong
you can email us rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com
that's rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com
we
are looking at a movie that is certified
fresh which is the good news
at 76 percent which for any
run-of-the-mill movie jacqueline is
pretty
good numbers it gets you into most
colleges but
this is an mcu movie and this has
avengers on the poster
so you'd think it would be in the 90s
with the rest of those flicks
it does have an 83 percent audience
score
but of all the avengers movies it's the
lowest on the tomato meter and audience
score
and when people do their mcu lists which
is now like what 23 24 movies deep
they usually have avengers age of ultron
on the lower side of that so we're going
to get into all of that
why certain fans don't think it holds up
what it did to set up the
the future of the mcu as we now know it
a whole lot of stuff to get to plus a
very special guest uh before we get into
all of that jacqueline
can you tell me succinctly what happens
in adventures age of ultron
no i can't but i'm gonna give it a try
all right we continue the adventures of
the avengers of course this is earth's
mightiest heroes they consist of captain
america iron man black widow thor
the hulk hawkeye and we're adding some
new folks
into nick fury's best fighting machine
tony stark and his crew have been faced
with some
we say big challenges from outside folks
and so they decide
they're gonna make a robot and so they
make ultron that is
tony stark and bruce banner and then
ultron turns evil kills jarvis
and then the avengers are off to the
races to try and save
the world along the way they meet two we
can't call them mutants because this is
not the right universe but that's what
they are
scarlet witch and her brother who is
quicksilver he's really fast she's
really weird to quote
maria hill and yeah they are
sort of doing ultron's bidding until
they realize that ultron
is going to end the world and in doing
so ultron decides that he
as a progeny wants to make his own he
makes his own
which becomes vision they take the mind
stone thor goes on some adventures and
it's a
really really big movie with a lot of
things going on
but i still love it ambition
is just the beginning point and it's a
nice little warning flick for all those
people out there jacqueline like me and
my brother were his kids where you're
trying to build a robot in your garage
and then all of a sudden you say wait is
this even a good idea
will i get grounded i don't know if my
mom would have grounded us if she ever
caught the robot that my brother and i
made it basically consisted of stealing
of three of her pots
lucy our producer is a mom lucy
your kid is not old enough yet to be
building robots as far as we
know or do we she loves robots
um she could potentially be building
them in her bedroom at night i don't
know she never goes to
that bed be the sign of a robot builder
well
our our special guest that we're
welcoming in today he's not only one of
my good buddies
he might be a cyborg as a matter of fact
because i've just never seen anybody
bring
so much positive energy to each and
everything that he does not since the
late great brody stevens has the word
positive energy
so closely correlated with someone i
know
and that would be a huge comic book
fan incredible host
director producer does all the things on
all the shows
he is coy john drew coy welcome
you are now amongst your friends i'm
excited to be here and i'm excited to
weirdly talk
negatively about something i feel mostly
positive about
by by way of the universe but it's going
to be a very not tonally
coy day because this movie's got some
problems all right man well let's roll
up our sleeves to get into it then the
show is rotten tomatoes is
wrong the score is currently 76
is rotten tomatoes wrong on this koi it
sounds like you think they might be
rotten tomatoes is wrong in that
it should be fresh but not this fresh
i'm talking 60
i'm talking 59 i'm talking this is a
warning shot to the entire mcu of how it
could have gone horribly horribly wrong
it should be fresh but this movie almost
set us on the wrong course for the
entire future of the empire that is the
mcu a myopic
look at life
take from koi jaclyn is fried tomatoes
right
you're reading my article well i love
your article and that that is the the
basis that i usually stand by
but you look at the way this the ship
got steered after this film
this is looking back at phase two
through phase three lens we can see a
lot of merit but retroactive history
doesn't work for
a moment in film so like when this
initially came out
this was a series of scenes in search of
a movie
when you build to new movies later that
retroactively make them work that's
great but this is one puzzle not a
series of puzzles
and this movie was a hodgepodge of
trying to sell me things
it was a prequel sequel it was iron man
2 all over again
it was the only movie with an avengers
thing in front of it that felt like they
just went like
okay we need to put these scenes in for
later but let's not worry about the glue
that's going to hold it together
coming in hot the under armour the beats
the so many things it felt like a disney
film and this is the only one that feels
like a disney film it's the only one
that i felt like they were really
putting their fingers in it and they
learned some lessons
and then the russos took over but we'll
get into that later it's just a lot
it's a whole lot i am currently wearing
under armour shorts as i attempt to go
to the gym
after we tape this broadcast jaclyn
uh you have written about this film
extensively you have deep thoughts on it
do you agree with koi
is it a fresh movie that's just too high
in the tomato meat or is it
maybe not high enough i mean this is
probably the last time we're gonna say
this on this episode but i agree
with koi in the sense that rotten
tomatoes is wrong but not that it should
be barely fresh in the realm
of spider-man 2 girl
i would actually say that this movie was
judged a bit too harshly and it should
make itself
into that mid level 80 um place
of like some of the secondary but still
enjoyable
mcu movies like you know the first
ant-man again not a perfect movie had a
lot of good things going for it
things like that um this movie when i
really think about it and i will get
into it in more depth it is
a simone biles type situation
in the sense of you have to take into
account the difficulty
and i know that you can call it
retroactively making it fit but i
actually based on what we know
think that there was a framework that
they had to put in place on this it
wasn't about retroactively making this
stuff work
these tent poles were laid down for the
road that they went in future and that's
really what caused it to feel
so disjointed and so although it is a
disjointed movie that has
a ton of issues as far as like
compelling narrative storytelling
for what it achieved i give it so much
of a pass and so it's one of those
situations like at the olympics where
they have to keep explaining to folks on
the announcers it's like
the reason why she got a higher score
even though she had a lower
um execution or she messed up is because
of the difficulty
so like this is that situation where the
difficulty was
so high they were asking so much of this
movie
that the fact that it is even passable
is a miracle
degree of difficulty uh you have
maybe hindsight being 20 20. there's a
lot to
there is a lot of adventures age of
ultron i'm gonna go ahead and say this
right now
and then i might regret it later i think
rotten tomatoes is wrong because
i don't think that the score is high
enough upon re-watching the movie and i
don't think i was just putting on my
2021 glasses to watch a movie that was
released in 2015 but
now i have some time to think about that
because as usual
our friend tim ryan the rotten tomatoes
expert review curator is going to come
in and let us know
what the critics were saying about
avengers age of ultron when it was
released in may
of 2015. so tim buy me some time
thanks mark so avengers age of ultron is
sort of considered this weird
disappointment in the marvel universe
which is very strange if you look at it
because
it's certified fresh on the tomato meter
it's 76 with 370 reviews and it's got an
83
audience score so what exactly is the
issue you look at that and you say well
this is
this is a pretty well reviewed movie
this seems like a success it made a lot
of money
and i think the issue was that the first
avengers movie was the culmination of
years and years of getting to know these
heroes
watching them fight together and it was
sort of the dream come true for any one
of us who
sort of dreamed of like having all these
superheroes from marvel in one place
so by the time the second one rolled
around we kind of knew
the formula a little bit better and it
seemed a little bit lacking by
comparison
so what some of the critics have to say
in a fresh review dwight brown from the
national newspaper publishers
association wrote there's little in this
film that's new
but it doesn't matter the characters are
still entertaining the action scenes
thrilling and near orgasmic
and the human relationships touching in
a rotten review however james barnelli
of real views wrote age of ultron
disappoints not because it's
irredeemably bad but because it fails to
achieve the level of its predecessor
in nearly every facet when avengers came
out there was a sense that
all these superheroes together was in
its own way kind of gigantic
and kind of thrilling and huge but what
you do for an encore
is do you make it even bigger do you put
in more superheroes do you make the
action scenes
even more bombastic and i think that's
what a lot of fans and critics struggled
with a bit
on this one not that it's necessarily
terrible it's just
not quite as novel and maybe bigger in a
way that doesn't feel quite as
exciting i don't know i think it's
pretty cool i liked it
excelsior um
i think tim might be our own personal
ultron did you just hear how soothing
his voice was but just with a tinge of
menace
of of the venom that some critics might
have for age of ultron
tim ryan you are the robot that
hopefully is going to put a shield
around the world but
might end up destroying us all i'm just
not sure which one so
yeah critics were divided on this one
and coy jacqueline i feel like a lot of
it is inevitable
comparisons to the first avengers
because we are so excited and when you
talk about the
degree of difficulty i thought joss
whedon had a monster task with that
first avengers movie getting them all
together into one movie and making it
coherent so now
we get a bigger story we get more
emotions out of age of ultron and we
certainly have a lot more to set up
but coy you feel like the movie just is
it just that it gets
muddled is there a scene that you can
point to that you say that is what i'm
talking about where this
movie is just not as fresh as the tomato
meter claims
so i i think listening to jacqueline
especially
i think we'd actually agree if this
wasn't an mcu film
i'm judging it on the merits not of
comic book movies but on mcu films this
is the movie that followed
iron man 3 winter soldier guardians of
the galaxy this is when the mcu knew who
it was
and i think it lost its path very
clearly in the scene that most people
that love comics talk about
the very shoehorned in thor tripping
balls in the water of a cave scene
um i'm not really sure at what point
they thought they should add an element
of selvig knowing more about mystic arts
than thor
i'm not sure at what point they thought
that him like imagining a future
ragnarok that they never really pay off
in the films that they did so so
carefully set up in the future
and i i think i misspoke i didn't mean
that that was a retroactive
improvement on the film i mean the film
is more enjoyable
retroactively for the viewers experience
because of end game so
because of infinity war and end game
your memory of
your experience at age of ultron
improves because you know where it pays
off
that's not to discredit them laying the
groundwork i'm saying when you watch the
film initially you can't give it the
credit of the payoff later
because it needs to be acknowledged like
the movie itself when you walk out and
see the credits
those are moments are what you have in
2015. now i can appreciate that the mcu
is an incredible tv series that are two
hour long episodes i love that about it
it's
24 episodes of my favorite show in the
world i'm an mcu junkie as you know
but you can't end an episode and go i
bet later on i'll like that more
you need to see it for what it is in the
moment which is why iron man 2 didn't
work because they kept trying to put
stuff in there so
for me the thor scene of hey this is
really gonna matter later ignore the
fact that right now it's
just crazy really uh establishes what
the whole movie feels like for me but
when they slow down
you're getting what joss whedon was
trying to build when they have the
farmhouse when they have all these
scenes that are actual dialogue between
the avengers
it doesn't feel like michael bay light
this movie has 10 third accept pieces
jacqueline jacqueline jump in there
because it looks like you have strong
thoughts
on the the thor hot tub time machine
well first of all i'm sorry there is no
woman watching that movie that is going
to be like oh they put chris hemsworth
in it then he's naked
stop it stop it don't do it
i don't care how nonsensical it is
there's literally a story on graham
norton where chris hemsworth said no
i've been training i'mma show it
and so he wanted to show it and i am
happy that he did
going back to that scene yes it doesn't
make any sense yes it's absolutely
ridiculous um and the whole way that
they set up ragnarok
is just bizarre because honestly i don't
think josh
knew where the hell that was gonna go
and he felt like they were giving him
this herculean task and honestly if you
want to know my personal opinion
that was a throwaway scene that was a
note that he had to do
and he's like you gotta make sure you
set up ragnarok and so he wrote that
stupid scene with eric selvig and he
takes thor out of the action because
that's what they told him to do
um if you really look at it this movie
is required to set up
every single standalone that they have
coming up after that in some minor way
they set up black panther they set up
the black widow movie which didn't
happen originally because joss was
supposed to be the person to direct it
and that's what sort of pushed it down
the list
and they they try to set up that movie
they try to set up what they hoped would
be the standalone hulk movie if they
could get the
rights back from universal they never
did and so they spread that across the
two
infinity war movies but like they're
setting up so much bs and i think he
just got tired of it so i look at that
scene and i
thought of it at the time i was like
this seems like a studio note
that's where i felt like people's hands
were in it and i just think he kind of
broke on that one but when you look at
all the other notes that he was asked to
do especially the ones that i think he
thought he was going to have a say in
like
civil war um there's a lot there
and i think you know if if we make the
argument that hindsight is 2020 i can
also say that at the time
when i was in the theater watching age
of ultron i wasn't thinking
when thor takes his shirt off and goes
into the water like oh this is a
throwaway scene first of all the one
thing i was thinking is uh
hashtag life goals the next thing i was
thinking is this is cool because it's
not
answering the question right away now
koi if this was like the end movie this
was avengers end game or
return of the jedi or return of the king
or something like that
and we leave with a scene and it's like
what the hell did that mean then i have
problems but it's it is such an episodic
feel
and by this time in the mcu we were
accustomed to that
that i i give it a pass particularly
because that's not the whole movie
sure most of the movie to me is this
fun adventure combined with a deeply
emotionally moving piece about the cost
of being a superhero but my favorite
scene is still the party scene i mean
the party scene
at the beginning i love the way this
movie opens because the movie opens in
it and it's like you're a kid reading a
giant panel
because it's just these awesome action
sequences the everybody is is working so
well as a team they're making fun of cap
and his prudish nature
and then we get to celebrate afterwards
it's like okay we just want another
super bowl
now we're gonna have the party and we
have war veterans there
we have some beautiful probably
instagram influencers there
you have folks walking around
everybody's trying to pick up thor's
hammer
and it just it it gives you all the
feels of why you love hanging out with
these characters it's not just that
they're saving the world it's just that
i genuinely want to be one of them or at
least
get a plus one to that party koi
whatever man it's a trick
please be my guest come on
really yeah
clint you've had a tough week we won't
hold it against you if you can't get it
up
you know i've seen this before right
good know how you night it
smell the silent judgment please start
by all means
never one to shrink from an honest
challenge get after it we go
it's physics physics all right so if i
lift it i
then rule asgard yes of course i will be
reinstituting
primonocta i totally agree and that is
why it's a very good comic book movie
but all the things that we just
let go and why it undermines the mcu
quality it is
it is a giant 24 episode series if you
got every episode of the fly episode in
breaking bad it's not the same show
i love the fly episode but that's
because it's unique in that it builds to
a different tone
but you can't have everything feel
disjointed and let things be otherwise
you become a not shared universe and you
have to start making the batman be
separate from the rest of the movies in
your universe
it's a very intricate to balance it all
so i i just think we should
hold it to a certain standard where iron
man 2
wasn't as good as iron man 1 and 3 and
right now this is rated
right near iron man 3 which i think is
not fair i think iron man 3
is a slept on masterpiece whereas this
should be seen with a little bit more
scrutiny
we'll come back when we talk about iron
man 3 but we're going to talk about this
and when we talk about this even i
i really want to like clarify this
because i did write a lot about where
this thing
places in the mcu and the herculean task
that joss wheaton was
was given to try and execute in this and
all the things that it set up
but i also just flat out enjoyed the
movie the movie itself was enjoyable to
me
i will admit it was engineered to be
enjoyable to me because of how many
people
in it they added that i love like first
of all
when they announced james spader as the
villain and that it was gonna be a
voiced character i was like
so all about it because for folks that
don't know um
before he was on boston legal and he got
like normal and then now he's doing like
uh nbc shows
james spader was weird james spader was
doing like a lot of sex
and weirdness back in the early 90s and
late and early 2000 late 90s and early
2000s i mean he did crash
which i'm not talking about the oscar
winner as another movie where people
have sex when they wreck cars
he did sex lies and videotape he did the
secretary which was like bdsm like way
before 50 shades of grey that dude was a
freak and like add in he was the mean
guy from pretty in pink i
love everything that james bader does
and then for him to do this
i was like they are bringing the freaks
to the mcu
also aaron taylor johnson who plays
quicksilver i was like all about him
he was for folks that don't know he's
married to
sam johnson who directed him in nowhere
boy really great actor
and he's gorgeous like let's just be
honest and he dates an older woman which
means that he's very comfortable with
his manhood so i'm like all about aaron
taylor johnson like he's like
oh my dude and so those things are
amazing but it has great moments and the
scene that i actually love
is the opening and i will tell you why
because first of all yes everyone talks
about language
and and that but like there's just so
many quotable moments from that language
is one of them also you know
big guy sun's getting real low like i
think about that payoff in thor ragnarok
and like i know that's a later thing but
still i just love that
everything that they're doing there and
the best one for me when tony stark
pushes open the door
when he's like going to find the like
hidden room that maybe has like the
tesseract
he pushes it and he goes yay just like
that
he just like he does a little like yay
and it's just robert downey jr having
so much fun playing that character that
he felt the freedom
to do just that little throw away and it
was
perfect it's like he's in that character
he's become it it's like
they're they're stitched together at
that point and it's that way with so
many of the characters so
i love the opening scene
[ __ ] language jarvis what's the view
from upstairs the central building is
protected by some kind of
energy shield wait a second no one else
is going to deal with the fact that cap
just said
language i know
just slipped out the opening scene is
great and i am such a fan of when i get
to use big words like juxtaposition on
this show because when you put
that opening battle sequence where we're
we have
quips we're we're shooting bad guys
we're winning
and then you pair it with the end with
sokovia where
the film has all led up to this moment
where ultron is just basically going to
take over the world and eradicate
humanity and so the only way to save it
is we have to fight
and a lot of folks in sokovia are going
to lose their life because
half of their country is getting lifted
uh literally levitated above ground
so we can fight this evil and it's so
serious and it's so
dreadful there's some moments of levity
obviously because of the avengers and
who the cast is but
for the most part it's just weighs on
you in a way that i felt it as an
audience member that i didn't feel with
avengers
or any other superhero movie until that
point that is what sticks out about age
of ultron to me
is that we very rarely
talk about the expense of being a
superhero the the bodies
and the lives that are lost and what
that does to a superhero psyche because
yes you probably saved people you
probably saved more people from dying
but you still
weren't able to save everybody so you
get to see some of that
tortured soul that even in batman films
it's hinted at but it's never really
pointed out if batman has a bad night
and a bunch of people die what does that
do to him look at mark ruffalo in this
film
when he's he's recovering from hulking
out and he's realizing what he just did
like dude murdered a lot of people
accidentally wasn't his fault but he
killed a lot of people
and so to go from the first movie where
it's avengers and it's fun and games and
i hope we save new york and i hope all
these buildings don't fall on anybody
to this where no the building's fell on
a lot of people it first of all hints at
stuff we're going to get in later mcu
movies things that are going to come
back from sokovia
but we also just feel everything with
these heroes and i think the movie sets
us up like that coy
i think the movie opens up we're we're
on a fun adventure we're at a cool
party and it says hey don't you want to
be like these people okay we'll now see
what they really go through
so i most my arguments have been
narrowly looking at just this so
expanding it out to comparing it and
putting it in the the scope of the mcu
the opening scene is actually one of the
things that that really uh worked but
didn't if you compare it to the rest of
the mcu
because there's a lot of weightlessness
to it if you look at the actual
action set pieces individually iron man
has as you know as quips and things but
they do this thing where they undermine
the jokes which
you you specifically can appreciate why
this doesn't work for me there's a scene
where iron man's getting shot at and
he's like no no stop let's talk about
this that's the joke
that's the beauty of it is downey
delivering that wonderfully
the follow-up joke to that is him
shooting this and
uh shooting them all with like
tranquilizers and saying like good talk
that's your alley-oop that's where it
lands but then they undermine
all of that by having some henchmen go
no it wasn't which makes it not funny it
makes it a kids movie
and these aren't kids movies like
there's moments that are like
why didn't you trust downey jr to be
funny you cast robert downey jr like
let the moment and let the joke land
don't show like hey
that was a joke and that that kind of uh
when the movie opened with
remember this is funny i was like but
this is an avengers movie this isn't a
kid show
and and also like captain america um
throwing the
motorcycle is awesome but now we have no
level of what power set cap is in the
first avengers
cap is jumping around outside the
helicarrier and you're worried about him
because he's hundreds of feet thousands
of feet in the air
in this movie he throws a motorcycle in
the opening scene so you're like
wait is anyone not super powered except
hawkeye
like there's so many moments that
undermine the whole series no that was
already established in winter soldier
they already made him leg man in that
movie
so no koi when you throw a motorcycle
you want to get your legs into it for
everybody listening at home if you're
throwing motorcycles as part of your
workout it's not in your back okay you
want to stabilize your core
with your quads and with your hands and
your glutes that's how
i mean he is america's ass after all
there's a reason why he's america's ass
that's just training he's throwing ten
motorcycles
three sets of that i i i get that you
could be confused with
with the powers or the level of their
powers because it does seem like
some of our superheroes are able to
survive a lot more than they would have
in films leading up to this moment but i
just i i kind of write that off as like
well that's the training of being a
superhero it's like
steph curry his rookie season in the nba
probably not as productive as he was
five seasons into the nba when he was
probably the best point guard on planet
earth
and th this film though with sense of
humor
i always look at the villain and and
with with ultron in particular he's got
because he's in the mcu it's like well
what you're going to be villaining not
crack jokes
but he's got such a subtle
such a dark sense of humor
that i expect yeah dude that's the
kicker for me
i think the sense of humor worked
because it came off as menacing jaclyn
you feel the same way
absolutely that was the other reason why
on top of it you know
getting the dude from stargate to do it
like it was it was also the fact that
his voice can have
that sort of like venomous feel to it
but also um be comedic
like he could literally say something
that would reference your death
and you would maybe want to giggle about
it like that is
some power and you can only do that with
certain voices can do that
you know and and james spader clearly
has one of those voices so
i loved everything that he was doing is
ultron also not the only great voice
work that was going on
this is just a me thing um there was a
show on hbo called rome
nobody watched it but if you're like a
period piece like like people in
costumes person like myself
it's the movie but carrie condon is in
that and she actually voices
friday who takes over for jarvis slash
vision
will takes over for jarvis when he
becomes vision and i just loved
uh i just love the fact that they put
her voice in there because she's got a
really great voice and i thought that
was like a great turn from vision you
got to bring in
i don't know some flair to it you don't
often hear like a i think she's either
scottish or irish coming
uh that heavy in an mcu movie with that
kind of accent james spader
i i love through 90 of the film because
he is james spader especially with
you know the the secretary and all the
things jacqueline was speaking to
but i think that the and it might be
studio might be joss but the moments
that i really like are when they take
their time and when they
let things land and they don't undermine
it with humor that's the
very wonderful balance i think the mcu
has landed is i love the amount of quips
and jokes the marvel comics
are fun to read that's why we read them
even catholic guilt-ridden daredevil is
funny because that's the tone of the
world
but there's moments in this like right
seconds after quicksilver killed spoiler
alert for a six-year-old movie
seconds after he's killed they cut to a
james spader joke where hulk jumps in
the quinjet and he goes
oh for god's sakes and i'm like but he
just died let us have this moment of
like mourning
and then they cut back to hawkeye
carrying them onto
like an escape raft so we're supposed to
go like oh i feel horribly oh that was
kind of funny oh i feel horribly it's
like
just move that edit slide that [ __ ] 20
seconds let me actually
be impacted for a moment and that's kind
of like another
thesis statement from my problem is
every time they have cap like
fighting ultron there's a weird action
figure line like
can you keep up and there's no other
movie in the mcu
where cap is throwing out like bro
slogans it's like they were like wait
chris evans is from boston what if he
says this silly thing
and like the movie just has a lot of
those moments that don't feel like the
rest of the mcu
in a bad way i will ask you this though
because this is the other thing too now
is like the more
the more you talk to people about movies
who make movies
the more you realize the literal like
divorce proceeding
level of argument that happens
when they make them like literally i
mean think about the most venomous
divorce you've ever thought of and that
is like one day on a movie set
because it's the same situation of like
you guys are married to each other in a
lot of ways
and you're trying to get something done
and everyone's got different priorities
and so you gotta like
argue this stuff out and i feel like
josh
wheaton's language is reeled in by
studios a lot of the time
like his bro your more problematic
things
i think they let the language go on this
one because of the bigger ask
on the story so i think because if you
look at avengers and you look at this
one
you can see where he got smoothed over
on that one and this one as far as the
like dialogue was concerned it didn't
feel smoothed over maybe it was a timing
issue
i don't know it just didn't feel as
polished as far as like
this joke definitely belongs here this
joke lands you know what i mean
um so again i i it's me looking past the
glass a little bit
and and taking that into account but it
can't be denied like i'm sorry like yes
we're looking back on this with like
rose tinted glasses knowing where it
goes but you can't take that away now
like okay well people didn't appreciate
citizen kane when it was out it doesn't
mean that we don't know that it's
masterpiece now and if you're
in now which what we are and you're not
taking that into account
i think you're missing half of what the
movie did i think that if we were
looking at avengers age of ultron i
always go to quantum of solace oddly for
a comparison like this because
we all love casino royale the first bond
movie with daniel craig and then juan
masalas came out and we're like what the
hell was that leaving the theater but
then
at least the way i rationalized the
paying 15 bucks for a ticket because i
live in l.a
is okay well that probably sets
something up that's going to pay off in
the next movie
and i don't know that juan masalas did
that but i love skyfall
and so it at least got me to the next
movie but i think what this did it not
only got us to the next movie avengers
age of ultron
you had ultron come out and then i
believe it's ant-man and then you're
right into captain america's civil war
as far as mcu timeline goes
and so if you have a movie that not only
sets all that stuff
up but you can enjoy a majority of that
ride
but i do want to stress it's not just
that i'm like loving and shoving popcorn
into my face and laughing at all the
adventurous jokes and looking at all the
cool action scenes like
i do feel a new emotional depth was
reached with this movie
and one of the scenes that pretends to
that
is the farm house scene where we all
our our heroes need need a safe house to
hide out at for a while and so
lo and behold hawkeye who the hell knew
clint barton's got a family
and yeah they're cool he's married to
linda carnellini for god's sakes and
he's got two beautiful tykes running
around
and so we all go retreat to this farm
for a little bit and
you talk about being overwhelmed with
company imagine having like the world's
greatest heroes just all crash at your
pad
for a few days and so relaxed
by the way she was just like oh i know
who you are what
so cool with it and and she is so cool
with letting her husband go play with
these big boys and girls and it's like
hey let's remember clint ain't got any
special powers okay
sorry didn't go ahead this is an agent
of some kind
gentlemen this is laura
i know all your names
oh i'm coming hi
sweetheart hey buddy how you guys doing
dessert look at your face smaller agents
oh my goodness
did you bring any nuts why don't you hug
her and find out sorry for barging in on
you yeah we would have called ahead but
we were busy having no idea that you
existed
i love your avenging that was so cute
yeah wait a minute we haven't gotten
we're getting a hawkeye television show
i think but
we hadn't gotten a hawkeye stand-alone
movie but you could argue if we did
that parts of this are setting that up
too because this is the most we've
learned about hawkeye in this movie
i mean every major thing that happens
with him later as far as like
emotional is related in some way to
stuff happens here his relationship with
nat
his family like all the stuff that
happens with him later again i know bros
colored glasses but
this movie did a lot and i don't i also
just want to add since we're talking
about people
andy circus as ulysses claw listen
i'm i love that he made the choice by
the way andy circus made the choice to
make him south african
which was just like such a brilliant
touch
and i could watch him talk about kettle
fish on repeat
for 24 hours straight and it would not
lose an inch of enjoyability
this is your first time intimidating
someone
i'm afraid i'm not that afraid everybody
is afraid of something
cuttlefish deep sea fish
they make lights disco lights
to hypnotize their prey and then
i saw a documentary it was terrifying
this is one of those retrospect things
for me so i will side with koi on on
this one thing is when i was watching it
because i totally forgot andy circus
pops up in it as
claw and and when i saw him i was like
oh right he's in this and i had no idea
why he was in it at the time i saw it
but now i love that he's in it because i
know all the things that happened since
then so that's
that's literally me ratifying what col
what what coy has said about this film
to this point but
so koi i agree with you as far as the
claw thing goes here's my question about
any circus this movie
did he and and again i'm only i'm i
don't body shame anyone i tried to body
uplift
did he bulk up insanely for this movie
or is that just how he looks all the
time
i think he did he's he's a really mobile
like the way he moves for his work i
think he's always been physically fit so
he knows like the
how to build so i think he just used all
of his training in mocap to be like how
do i become an animal physically
just thicken this and i guess i'm
comparing him to gollum and i'm like wow
gollum's really been hitting the protein
shakes because he's just like so
he's all forearm too he's got like
specific gains
i do think that was a little bit of like
he like the
the pl the eight movies were literally
right at the same time like
one of the last ones i think so i think
that was really
that was like the second one i take that
back it was the second one the next one
came later after that
dude just give me more of andy circus
that that role and the one thing i
thought of when he handed him vibranium
is like oh yeah
sterling sterling k brown help you get
that like
like randall from this is us help you
get that because like when you go to
when you go to black panther that was um
uh
michael b jordan's dad who would like to
give away that video
whatever i love the idea of him coming
around off the ape set and being like
i've trained for this my entire life and
being like
ready to be physically claw he's just
he is he is so good but that is another
one of those scenes where you watch it
and you say well i'm sure this is going
to pay off
like again i guess at that point if that
was like the first or second movie in
the mcu i'm like well y'all are really
biting off more than you can chew but
i think by that point i just trusted the
mcu i mean this again
is the franchise that really established
itself as the post-credit people
and so now you're getting basically
three or four post-credit scenes within
the context of the film
which i i can understand it can be
overwhelming but it's also like look at
all the candy we get look at all the
things we have to talk about about what
the future could hold which transitions
us to our next segment which is
out of movie scenes just so far as let's
talk about
what did surround this movie in the
making of it because as jacqueline and
coy have hinted at
joss whedon this movie i mean anytime a
movie making experience makes you leave
twitter
you know that that it was something it
was a thing
and with this what was so cool about
um reading some of the research that our
uh our beautiful researcher mark
hoffmeier
put all this together i'm reading this
thing about how
the the thor the hot tub thor scene was
demanded by the studio joss whedon had
no idea what exactly we're doing what
we're setting up but the studio demanded
it and so
joss whedon used that farmhouse scene
which the studio wanted to cut
as his collateral he's like okay well if
i do this scene for you then we got to
leave the farmhouse sequence in there
and so
i think that if we had seen a movie that
didn't have hot tub thor
or the farmhouse scene i think we get a
lesser movie
yeah i i agree the farm i've seen is my
favorite entire secret it's actually one
of my favorite sequences
in the mcu the farmhouse stuff is so so
important and i
and i think that the hot tub thing is
worth that cost like the the deficit of
one of my least favorite scenes is worth
one of my favorite scenes i
i think the mcu is like going to your
favorite restaurant for me my experience
is
every single time i go to this
restaurant it's absolutely delicious
and the age of ultron experience was
just an adequate meal
so at worst i'm just like it was a time
i went to the restaurant
so it's worth having that delicious bite
of the farmhouse for like the lukewarm
bite that is the
the tripping balls thor but at the same
time my standard for the restaurant is
gonna stay so very high
that when i hear stories like joss
whedon quitting twitter i'm more upset
that it happened because of the
transition to power i think this had a
lot to do with
disney just buying the the you know the
entire studio that was marvel
this was the first officially disney
branded marvel film of memory serves the
ads felt
a little more disneyfied like this was
the first time i was like oh someone
bought my restaurant
i'm aware that there's a new chef and
they're gonna find their balance
and like the russo brothers became the
new head chef and i was all about that
thank you russo brothers
like that is a great chef to have in the
back of the house but while they're
transitioning and the old chefs teaching
the new chef all the tricks
i tasted the difference is a little
salty and i'm aware of it
so that's that's the issue i have with
ultron a little salty
that might be the greatest comparison
i've ever heard on the show jaclyn we've
been doing this for a while now boy
that's a standing ovation from producer
lucy that is
that is something special and and it
does
jive like i i that that plays with me i
understand
the restaurant because it's not like you
go to like like for me i'm not going to
go to cheesecake factory have one bad
meal and be like well i guess this
restaurant's done
it's like no there's so much on the menu
to enjoy just give it another shot
yeah yeah um i i don't know if it's like
the menu
for me actually if i'm if i'm thinking
about it this way i think
this movie and how it ended up with the
joss disney relationship
is more interesting than anything that
happened as far as like
what went wrong or what is that this guy
was their
golden boy prior to this movie and after
this he couldn't even like get a job
with them doing
anything i just like it was just like an
instant
sour ring of everyone's opinion of it
and
the and they were pissed at him for
making the the shield tv show
like the fact that he couldn't be their
person to only focus on the mcu
they were upset by that and if you look
at it the russos for the most part
were solely focused on avengers until
like right before the end
when they started doing some more
production work
that's interesting and and around the
same time you started to hear
of directors attached to various
standalone mcu films
dropping out and and these are directors
that are no that are names like joss
whedon was and
i mean when edgar wright or i i think uh
was ava duvernay attached to one at one
point um
and and they start to and then they say
oh well creative differences or whatever
and you say okay well that happens and
it's more public because it is this
gigantic franchise now but
i think people are wondering well who is
really pulling the strings
it's like ultron it's like okay well who
really is the
who's who is in in charge who is the
robot controlling this world
is it the director the filmmaker you
hired to do the job
or is it the studio who has these 20
movies that you need to set up and
you're kind of
force-feeding the director and so from
the narratives that were coming out
around that time
it did seem like this is disney slash
the mcu saying what they want
and i don't know if the russos came in
and just jived with them so well after
that i don't know if ryan coogler came
in and had a fantastic pitch
if they had to sell coogler on it but it
it seems like we got
more artistic voices into the mcu
despite that but i i don't know if
if avengers age of ultron was the
breaking point i don't know if it was
either
um i was just gonna say i don't know if
it was either but i will say as far as
the convincing ryan coogler i can't
attest to that i did the black panther
set visit
and uh nate moore who produced uh black
panther and i think he was
at least an ep or something maybe on
civil war he
um talked about how he had to have a
conversation with ryan to be like look
we
we are going to support you in this
story because he took convincing because
he had heard
that marvel was a difficult place for
directors to work creatively i mean this
is after ava had already walked away
from the process of making that movie
with them
edgar wright had left the ant-man
situation
um i mean yeah there'd been already
people saying okay is this
really where i want to be making my next
movie
oh patty jenkins with thor uh the dark
world she was originally gonna do that
and then she left the project because of
creative differences so
it's it's really interesting to think of
how that thing would have went
differently
um had they maybe loosened up i i also
think that
the timing with this was like promoter
leaving soon thereafter with his like
his straw mom of control because if you
look at you look at this movie there
wasn't even black widow toys because
that guy was such a
specific i'm not going to get into it uh
but it was basically
just for a little bit of context it was
pearl model pro motor was was running
but
the the tv division i think but then he
was kind of overstepping his bounds
somewhat with feige into the mcu and so
when you didn't have that one figurehead
looking over all of it you had the tv
versus the movies for a while
it it there was just that conflict that
needed to be resolved and so people oh
he was originally feige's boss though
i was overseeing everything yeah he was
overseeing everything and then they made
him tv
yeah like at first he was overseeing
everything and kevin feige was like
a lower rung producer and then they
moved him over to tv and then they're
like just get this guy out of here
didn't he buy like all imitation brand
soda or something like like the cat like
that wouldn't die soda for the premieres
he refused to buy chicken these are
making a billion dollars he's like whoa
whoa whoa let's go to costco real quick
let's be easy on this
are we talking like shasta yeah
we're talking though yes oh no i'm not
gonna throw rc cola
in the royal crown has its own thing
cheerwine has its own demographic
that is a quality soda but yeah when you
start talking about your your dr
perkies of the world then you start
getting into a pearl mudder
cheap territory but i think that's how
we got ryan coogler and the directors
with such vision in phase three was we
had kevin feige saying like
hey hey that guy's gone talk to me now
and then you get your taika's your ryan
cooglers your geniuses that have vision
and
can live by the rules of this because
that's what's so hard about marvel is
you're playing by both
the show runner standard which is kevin
feige your director's vision
and living in the the giant moving train
and machine that is the marvel cinematic
universe so
i think that some of the best directors
can't do that even if they're the best
directors
but i also think you have to have a
really beautiful way to handle people
which kevin feige does which is which is
what
the mcu is more about the incredible
machine that kevin feige's been able to
do
as this benevolent uh leader of people
and i and i think that when ike was
there you got your age of ultron's you
got you're not getting a black widow
movie you got your
insane john cheadle choice you got your
uh rachel uh what what's her name
rebecca ferguson not getting to be the
villain in iron man 3 because he thought
the fire breathing guy would sell more
toys why did that guy breathe fire we'll
never know
um there's just so many so many things
that just there's a little moment that
it's tainted in the mcu and i think this
lives right around there
okay so um to kind of put a button on
the industry
talk i do have to go to back to the
world of opinions
and say with everything that we know
about the making of this movie
everything we know about watching the
film
where does this rank in our top mcu
movies of all time because
corey jacqueline i have seen lists that
have this
not only in the double figures but in
the 20s where
it's like people have thor the dark
world and then avengers age of ultron
and then the incredible hulk i think the
incredible hulk doesn't get enough love
either
but this movie i upon
and i i texted lucy as soon as i
finished watching ultron
it immediately went into civil war
because i hit the button to put it into
civil war because i wanted to see
captain america civil war
and i made it through most of that movie
the same night and i was like i don't
know which one i actually liked better i
liked
the introduction of black panther and
spider-man in civil war but
man ultron held up a lot more than i
thought it did so i'm going to put this
at least in my top
10. uh
i don't know i think it's 10 but if it
isn't 10
it's definitely like very low teens like
11 or 12.
and i only say that because i like weird
things like the doctor strange movie
that everybody hates
like i dig that thing like none other i
love
love love that movie is that your
favorite one what's your favorite mcu
film jacqueline
bunning come on
black panther like really
i'm not gonna say it first of all i
guess it's racist for you to presume
but it's also like beyond belief for me
to say anything different
no actually because when you said come
on the first thing i thought of was okay
wait which movie has more naked thor in
it
ultron since you just that's where my
head went guardians so i would have got
strong too you're like i like weird i'm
like guardians guardians one maybe no
you all are ridiculous no we're so
progressive
oh no i'm sorry i'm gonna go with the
movie that was
that had kendrick lamar on the
soundtrack yes that is definitely
my favorite in cu i i will get i will
give a nod to
to run the jewels for uh for inspiring
us all with the first black panther
trailer
um black panther's probably in my top
five now it i don't
god it coy this is tough buy me some
time do you have your favorite mcu movie
if i'm going sexy weird i'm standing by
my guardians uh but
they're not my number one but like it's
my number one sexy weird i think my
number one
is winter soldier um and then i think
guardians and iron man one dance at
number two
uh just because without iron man we
don't have the flavor of the entire
universe and if you rewatch it it
doesn't feel like a 12 year old film
um this to be honest and this is gonna
i'm so sorry internet
this probably lands around number 20
for me and the entire mcu but
if you looked macro that means it's in
my top 50
of like movies because i love the mcu so
much that like
i gotta give the caveat just because
this is 20 in the mcu means
it's still in my upper echelon of film
but look at how many mcu movies are
amazing like winter soldiers civil war
iron man i think iron man 3 is genius
guardians like
it's just because of the goodness see
that's
that's the weirdness here it's like i
don't like the first captain america
that much
i don't like pretty much all the iron
man except for the first one that much
i still by the way when i say don't like
them that much i mean i'm not obsessed
living for every second of it like other
ones but but i also like
really like the first thor movie and so
many people hate that movie like i
lived for the first thor movie
absolutely but yeah but i didn't dig
ant-man as much
i i i still stick with the first iron
man
avengers um i mean infinity war end game
are great movies too
but civil war's way up there black
panther's way up there producer lucy do
you have a favorite mcu movie
of all time i saw you go crazy when coy
said
guardians of the galaxy is that going to
be your final answer yeah i'm actually
i'm
i'm koi light i am i'm the same iron man
and guardians are tied
iron man as a film i think would be the
only one that martin scorsese wouldn't
talk [ __ ] about
like you know on a filmmaker level but
um
it really is incredible john favreau is
a genius
and guardians to me i love space stuff
and i love
to me i'm a big fantasy lover sci-fi
lover so
that felt the most out there and
i just love ensemble you know
quote unquote freaks in a movie together
so watching that was so much fun
did you like the greatest showman yeah i
i i didn't when i first watched it if
you remember and then i was like i'm a
changed woman
i love it now so if you apply all my
criticisms i think the age of ultron to
my top three
i think winter soldier being my favorite
it allows for comedy but serious action
with world building with escalation it
has even more villains than ultron
but it doesn't fall into a lot of the
tropes that this one the third act of
this
is just another grey minions with a
space hole instead of the hole going up
the hole's coming down it's the same
third act
if you apply the my problems with comedy
and you look at guardians
guardians builds an entire team
instantaneously and has the weird humor
of
you know a joss whedon type humor
through james gunn and it doesn't have
weird throwaway adr lines
if you look at the pacing issues i think
in this one iron man which started the
whole damn thing
is paced like a masterpiece and as his
avengers this movie is two minutes
longer than avengers and feels four
times as long
there's just issues it's a salty dish
it's a salty i did not say that it was a
perfect movie
i said that it achieved the we done the
impossible
come on now
seriously i feel like uh like jack and i
are coy's parents and
and we all took our son to see this
comic book movie and the parents
just had a good time at the movie and
our kid seems bummed out about it for
some reason
if i wasn't a professional comic nerd i
would i would be very with if i was
going into this like yay
then yes but i have to be scrutiny
because the bar is so high if we let the
bar slip it all falls apart it's a very
delicate puzzle
it's a delicate ecosystem i i i do like
winter soldier more
upon re-watching i just i'll never
forget winter soldier is just one of
those movies when christian and i were
doing schmoe's reviews
i i had the gall to give winter soldier
like a 3.8 out of five schmooze as
opposed like five out of five everybody
else was given and i just got
crushed online the only place people
could find you
was the youtube comment section i do
have some trivia for adventures age of
ultron the year it came out at the box
offices but before
i get to that little trivia tease koi
john drew
it was a pleasure as always to see you
once again
hear your smiling face enjoy all your
criticisms all of your love for this
movie the mcu
where can all the kids find you out
there and what are you working on right
now
uh so i host a show called comic book
shopping because if you guys couldn't
tell by this rant that i didn't even
talk about
how stan lee had to make thor spin the
hammer so there were physics to actually
allow him to fly versus superman who
just flies and now
the physics of this film really bothered
me because of stan lee's integrity
didn't even get into that because i
don't want to go that nerdy on you guys
that is the realm i like to live in
uh i do a show called comic book
shopping where i bring the people that
create this art to the comic book store
and i show them the source material so i
read
about 300 comics a month so i have a
rolodex of everything new and old then i
show people stuff they might like so
while i'm interviewing them i'm going
through my rolodex of comics then i
curate a list of things they might enjoy
to try to convert people to comic book
people
i also have a show called coy cast which
is a podcast about everything comic book
news i do a show
on youtube called koi cubed i'm a
narcissist there's a theme here
uh and then a bunch of other stuff on my
youtube and then my patreon i do reviews
that people select so if they think i
might like or not like something
i review those and i rate every single
comic i read so the hundreds of books i
read i give a rating for each and every
one of those
so people can save some money and
discover some new comic books so patreon
youtube
podcasts i'm all over the internet with
comic book stuff but most of all i want
to say before i lose this audience that
won't look at me because i scrutinize
this film
i love this movie i just think like
jacqueline said the ecosystem if we let
any litter clutter the beauty that is
the mcu we worked so hard to get here if
we didn't have blade
if we didn't have x-men we didn't have
spider-man leading the path to iron man
1
we wouldn't be in this glorious golden
age of superheroes so if we let
we let the iron man twos fall through
the cracks then we suddenly are living
in a
x-men three age and i will not stand for
another x-men origins wolverine i won't
stand for it
i feel like we're arguing about the
sokovia accords like we need oversight
from the studios no no we can't have the
studio be the one that dictates
everything
um go support koi's patreon um because
now everybody can go there and donate a
little bit of bucks
to a very hard-working friend of mine
every month but more importantly once
you do that
you can demand that he just keeps
rewatching age of ultron over and over
and over again just make him keep
reviewing it week after week after week
if i if i don't give you anything inside
the mcu koi so i'm taking away agents of
shield and all that other stuff
what's like a streaming recommendation
that you can throw to people who
if if they liked age of ultron or maybe
they had an issue with age of ultron and
you say okay well here's something
kind of like that that was done better
um you know i
my streaming poll was something
completely outside of comic books uh i
was gonna recommend
a show that is trying to get a fourth
season renewal
that is amongst my favorite bit of
content in the history of
anything uh the show kingdom on netflix
is a show about masculinity and a very
new light and it doesn't look at it as
toxic
or positive it doesn't look like it
doesn't look at it with a judgmental
lens
and it's about fighters and i feel like
the mma community
gets judged very broadly i feel like the
world of fighting is seen as as
you know uh bloodsport but there's so
much art in martial arts that doesn't
get looked at
and this this show takes its time to
really look at this family dynamic
about the world of fighters about this
incredible culture that a lot of people
immediately judge
much like comic books so my parallel is
i grew up looking like flash thompson
but i think like peter parker
and i've been judged as both a bro and a
nerd so i feel like kingdom
allows my bro side to get some some
levity and it allows me to go like no no
we're not monsters we just punch each
other because we love it for the sport
so uh mma means a lot to me and the show
kingdom
was unceremoniously canceled after three
seasons because it was on
audience networks which i didn't know
existed i was like a directv only show
now it's doing gangbusters on netflix
for good reason it's up there with
breaking bad for me as far as caliber of
show
frank grillo is a powerhouse doesn't get
enough i was gonna say
i knew once you said audience network
ironically i knew what show you were
talking about
i was like wait is that gorilla is that
the one with crossbones okay jonathan
tucker my boy jonathan tucker from back
home like he's a boston boy that
should be a multi-emmy award-winning
champion and he plays
this incredible powerhouse uh the show
is just it's so perfect and it's one of
those things that when people find it
they're like why didn't i see this five
years ago
save it before it's gone save kingdom
kingdom on netflix change my life
that's odd because my streaming
recommendation as it is each and every
week was gonna be
bloodsport uh you can find avengers age
of ultron on fandango now and voodoo
currently
jacqueline coley where can all the kids
find you and all of your
tweets and witticisms and articles and
all the other hard work you're doing
well you can always head over to
rottentomatoes.com to read about what
i'm writing usually about this year's
oscar season very interesting
season um and also you can follow me on
anywhere
at that jaclyn because i'm that girl
that talks about movies
coy this is really fun sir i'm i'm just
gonna go ahead and say that i
i had a great time i cannot wait to be
doing a movie that we see the same way
but i don't feel like i
have to tarnish because of my opinion
like i'm not like it's almost rotten but
we say all the same things i just have
to say they're more aggressively
we're gonna agree in a movie and it's
gonna be a jaunt and i'm very excited
for this one
let's see if you all agree on the trivia
question so 2015 worldwide box office
four movies performed better at the
worldwide box office than avengers age
of ultron which is weird to say
one of them was obviously star wars the
force awakens
can y'all name the other two movies that
outperformed
avengers age of ultron at the worldwide
box office it was jurassic world that
year
koi john drew is on the board yes
got nothing no okay no i'm not scouting
i'm gonna give you i'm gonna give you
all a one word hint and i think you'll
get it
vroom cars oh fast and furious one of
the fastest
and furious yeah it was one of the
fastest i can't remember which one but
it was one of them
it was seven i think furious seven yes
it was jacqueline your
your guess was the best cards
cars was it mom's room
i love that um y'all can email us and
give us your suggestions we love hearing
from you
uh tell us what you love about the show
tell us what movies you wanted
let us know what what do you think is a
rotten movie that everybody else thinks
is fresh what all your friends think is
rotten what does the tomato meter say
rotten that you think
is a great movie hit us up anytime rt is
wrong
at rottentomatoes.com that's rt is wrong
at rottentomatoes.com
next week i'm just here to make coy
jealous because he's really missing out
jacqueline we are talking
about the movie you want to talk about
box office you want to talk about
worldwide box office you want to talk
about
blue people plugging their tails into
flying pterodactyls
then you're talking about james
cameron's
avatar
oh my gosh you know what's really funny
all i'm thinking about
is this big bang theory episode where
they talk about the fact that they put
their little tails
on the animals and they put their little
tails on each other
when they have sex they don't watch like
the tails are like
like by the way that's that thought has
lived
rent free in my mind for way too long
james cameron you think of that arch yes
that is next week's show folks so you
have avatar to look forward to koi once
again thank you so much for
everybody here the hard-working team
behind the scenes at rotten tomatoes
christian ruval cabo
lucy bruckner our glorious producer
jacqueline coley
i emily markell is saying thank you for
listening to rotten tomatoes is wrong
click that like button if you can rate
review us all that good stuff and until
next week remember kids
wash your tails
[Music]
you